and go you know what this timer means
every quarter second a user spends
staring at a blank screen instead of
interfacing with your app is a quarter
second more they're willing to close
your app and give their attention to
something else my name is Colt McAnlis
and misunderstanding all the complex
things that happen during your app
startup can lead to some serious
performance problems now see Android is
pretty smart when it comes to
understanding human performance
perception as soon as the user launches
your application Android will
immediately display a start window which
will stay around until your application
is fully loaded initialized and can draw
its first frame this behavior is most
often seen when your app is booted for
the first time but it can easily happen
other times as well like when the
activity is brought to the foreground or
after the user backs out of your app or
after some portion of your app has been
purged by the system to save memory
basically any time the user moves from
something else to your application
there's a chance you can see this type
of behavior the important point is -
here is this letting the user spend too
much time looking at the start window
gives them ample opportunity to get
bored and move on to other things and
taking too long in general could even
cause the application not responding
dialog to pop up neither of these are
very good for user retention so from a
technical side the whole process works
something like this when the user
launches your app the system does a bit
of work to load your application
information and create a unique process
for your app from there the system
process will display the starting window
and basically hang out until the
application is up and running
meanwhile the application process will
create the application object and launch
the main thread this is where your
startup activity will be initialized
created inflated and finally drawn it's
only at this point after the application
has drawn its first frame that the
system process then goes and swaps out
the start window for the application now
to be clear the majority of that entire
process happens pretty cleanly now
there's not really much chance that
performance can go off the rails however
there are three big areas where things
could become problematic that you should
keep an eye on the first thing you
should really take a look at is all the
work that goes into creating your
activity class most often there's lots
of heavy lifting that occurs during this
process but heaviest has to be the
inflation of layouts and loading of
resources that goes along with it this
is not a cheap process and if you're
layouts are too complex or you've got
some blocking logic in there this can
cause some really big problems on a
similar note make sure you take a look
at your application initialization for
really complex apps the initialization
of the app object often becomes a junk
drawer for lots of global classes that
might be used between activities so
there tends to be lots of work here that
could be deferred to later times or
perhaps loaded in a lazy load fashion
now there's lots of applications out
there which provide custom start windows
this is either done to help brand the
application or to make a slow load look
like a custom branded application now if
you're doing this to hide bad load times
obviously you should fix that first but
if you're doing it for branding then you
need to be aware that there's a right
and a wrong way to set this up so that
it doesn't influence the user perception
too negatively but before you run off
into the weeds and try to fix these
types of common patterns you need to sit
down and figure out if you have a
problem in the first place thankfully
Android has a few tools to help firstly
is displayed time for releases after
KitKat logcat will include an output
line which displays the amount of time
between when the process was launched
and the activity finally drawn to the
screen this can be helpful because it
gives you a general idea how long it
takes to occur for your application
oh by the way note if you want to see
this value inside of Android studio you
need to turn off filters for the logcat
output so keep that in mind
secondly is report fully drawn function
the displayed metric that's reported in
logcat is useful for most situations
where you'd like to track down the time
it takes to go from applications start
to first visible however in modern
application development there's often a
great deal of lazy loading that is
rather than blocking the initial drawing
of the window asynchronously loading
resources and views in the background
and updating the view hierarchy
accordingly the result is that while the
initial activity may be visible it may
not yet be fully loaded with respect to
resources which could be considered a
separate metric to use when evaluating
launch time performance to address this
concern you can manually call the
activity report fully drawn function to
let the system know that your activity
is finished with its laid easy loading
third is method tracing while displayed
time and report fully drawn give a good
understanding of the overall load time
of your application they do not provide
details into what may be causing
particular parts of that pipeline to go
longer than expect it to gain more
insight in this area you can use the
start method tracing tool inside of
Android studio and finally as the big
one systrace when you add trace
functions inside of your on create
methods it will augment your logging
such that the systrace tool can properly
discover all the subsections and display
them in its graphing process and if
you're looking for more great
performance insight don't forget to
check out the rest of the Android
performance patterns content and be sure
to join the Google+ community to ask
questions from other perf groups so keep
calm profile your code and always
remember perf matters
you